what what what what what
you bad [ __ ] you you made it to
the church
what's up lisayet [ __ ] long five
[ __ ] days i miss you [ __ ] i
know it feels like longer than since
yeah we gotta figure some [ __ ] out here
and [ __ ] beautiful day to be alive
just taking a chance to make it happen
salute the flag grab your nuts whatever
the [ __ ] you got to do to remind you
you're in a [ __ ] american we don't
take [ __ ] from nobody [ __ ]
sup baby nothing that [ __ ] in ferguson
is scary it's [ __ ] scary and i talked
to joey fulato who called into the park
because he's from saint louis right in
st louis and he was taking he was
breaking it down for me how ferguson
is uh next to where it's going down
where he lives and he broke down the
three counties to meet the north end and
what happened well let me ask you
something good because
for i i understand that we need police
and that
there's one bad cop something
and now that the whole the whole thing
it seems like they're all going to [ __ ]
but i never really understood
is it something is because i'm so white
that they never really mess with me like
when you're walking down the street and
you see a cop do you think are you
worried they're going to mess with you
because you never know what could happen
you never know what could [ __ ] happen
in this situation you know it's like
three wrongs
don't make it right you know the cop
shoots the kid then they release the
video of him shaking down the [ __ ]
owner
and then there's looting and there's all
this stuff okay one mistake now let into
three others that we shouldn't be doing
right you know uh
listen man i've been in situations where
a cop has said to somebody that there's
been an accident there's been an
accident or there's an event
and you're walking by and the cop tells
you to move to the other thing and
you're like what are you saying hold on
you know you're in your thought and you
don't know what they're saying and
sometimes a cop will get into your face
i'm sure that's happened that never
happened to you like you're not walking
in the right thing hey you didn't i
[ __ ] tell you to cross the street and
you're like really is that [ __ ]
necessary
you know is that [ __ ] necessary and
now you get into a [ __ ] altercation
with a cop and you're always going to
lose oh yeah it's either going to give
you a ticket or why are you talking to
me that way or turn around let me frisk
you it always becomes that we have taken
the mat we have we have taken them
the
i don't know how to say the word not
tenderness we have taken the
the human interaction away from the
police officer yeah because now when
they're trained they're trained you know
they're shooting dogs
you know a dog is 10 feet away
put your dog away listen if that dog
ain't got a [ __ ] gun or he's not
charging me i understand putting your
hand on the holster you know i
understand everything i understand that
it's very tough to be a cop when i get
out of the car i don't know what i'm
going to walk into right i don't know if
you have a gun i don't know what but
instead of this officer saying my gun
went off
i discharged it too early or whatever
you know it gets covered up that right
away the cops coming they go [ __ ] them
he was just a black kid you know he's
probably a hood anyway that's the
mentality i'm telling you that's the
mentality okay okay he's just a [ __ ]
number he's not a human no more you know
we have taken the human interaction out
of being a police officer they're
trained now a certain way where they're
not supposed to listen to us and we're
all perks and we're all wrong
well do you hear about that
stop-and-frisk thing they had in new
york for a while yeah this kid recorded
the audio of it and it was terrible
terrible but it's and it's like because
you know that you have to have cops and
i'm sure i don't even know for the
majority but i'm gonna i'm i'm hoping
that the majority of cops are good
people and
part of me if a cop tells me to do
anything i'm just do it because whenever
i see these videos people put up of like
people outside bars of people like
yelling at cops and like resisting cops
i'm like why would you
like why would you do that like i and
and part of me was like well maybe you
should stand up for your rights and
stuff but the other part of me is like
they have guns
yeah yelling at me when i'm just walking
out of the club
why are you yelling at me or why am i my
brain doesn't even go there let's say
you're saying all of it let's say he's
just pushing you and you're like get off
me i didn't do nothing right away that's
resistant the rest
i mean and then it's ten cops look what
happened in staten island and i'm no
political activist i'm none of these
guys but this guy is a big black guy oh
[ __ ] they gotta die when they choked
them out really for selling [ __ ]
cigarettes
for selling untaxed cigarettes that's
what staten island was built on that's
what sammy the beau gravano did for 30
[ __ ] years you [ __ ] morons and you
got a black guy that's six foot [ __ ]
nine and the guy's saying i can't
breathe and the little guy johnny jiu
jitsu who's a purple belt just holding
on to this [ __ ] guy this cannot
continue because what's gonna happen is
there's some crazy [ __ ] out
there that will get a gun and we'll
start shooting cops in the [ __ ] head
it's happened before and then we sit
here and we gotta [ __ ] the salute as
they drive by listen we don't know what
happened we weren't there number one
number two and number three we don't
know what type of day that officer is
having okay you don't understand maybe
his kid just got caught playing hooky
and the wife is breaking his balls and
now i show up and this black guy doesn't
wanna he's just saying hey man you know
me what the [ __ ] are you bothering me
for yeah you know we'll turn around let
me the handcuffs don't fit and often i
jump out you don't you never know
you know you never [ __ ] know what
type of day a person is having okay and
that's what happens a lot of times in
these situations but what happens after
them
you know what does
looting that that doesn't have to do
with a cop what is you know i don't
understand the release maybe i didn't
grow up in those type of areas
but i did dumb [ __ ] like that when i was
a kid i did all that type of [ __ ] when
something happened you join up with a
with us a bunch of people and you're out
there yelling and screaming by the time
you get home you're like what was i
yelling screaming for and that's the uh
i think i think i don't know ferguson
but uh let's
so i was talking to paul about it and
she was like during rodney king her mom
and her dad looted not because they were
they were upset about black people but
they were poor and people were looting
and they needed food so i don't know for
is ferguson lower income because maybe i
guess it was a it used to be a good
neighborhood okay
i don't know
joey broke it down from yesterday it's
just so it's so scary that that could
happen here and it's gonna happen
because now they're going to let the cop
go the cops are going to get acquitted
always on the line and this is going to
happen there was a march yesterday in
downtown l.a about two cops killing a
kid that was mentally challenged
and then there was another one where two
cops again got into it with a guy and
they beat him up or something in front
of his kids
they shot him in front of his [ __ ]
kids so the humanitarian aspect not the
humanitarian the humane aspect you know
when i was growing up guys i got in a
lot of trouble and i had police contact
a lot
but i don't know what it was in those
early years in the in the late 80s and
the early 90s where they were still
cops that were human beings they'd
separate you what happened step back
lower your voice breathe okay what
happened and you had a chance for them
to explain yourself
without getting turned around or thrown
on the floor or fork or a [ __ ] tank
coming down the street since when did
police officers have tanks yeah are the
neighborhoods that bad i didn't know
that these [ __ ] people had
anti-fucking missiles oh [ __ ] yeah you
know and on the street to shoot and they
were firing like tear gas and rubber
bullets do you think part of it is like
budget cuts and they're just like
they're overworking them and then they
don't hire the best people anymore and
like that's part of the reason why i get
so upset during tax season it's like why
am i paying these high taxes and then
you're not
stop paying i don't know if the politics
i don't know who you should be paying
but
pay the cops more
and like you should have go ups like
maybe that maybe they're hiring people
who they wouldn't have hired before no
they're still hiring the same people
they're still going through the same
hiring
process it's the way we're getting
trained
it's the way it's the mindset that
they're getting let out into the street
at it's that it's the 10 years on the
police force
it's the being blind to to not
appreciate what the job is about anymore
you know when you get out of the car you
see three black guys there's a call over
the radio you're pulling your gun that
[ __ ] turns around bubble but you
don't know you haven't like i said you
you don't know what type of day you're
having and once a weapon gets pulled out
it's always bad [ __ ] yeah you know so
you know we're here talking about it i
don't have all the facts i'm not gonna
tell you i'm [ __ ] diane sawyer and i
got 20 people [ __ ] working and
looking at all the facts but i know the
top fact i know with black and white i
know how that works
i understand contact with police i've
had thousands of [ __ ] contact with
police so it's just a bad situation that
could settle down or might get worse and
it seems like every time these
situations flare in this country they're
getting worse and worse because it's a
[ __ ] powder cake yeah okay it fled up
in florida last summer with the tavon
martin you know it swelled at new york a
couple of years ago it's starting to
swell well it's like your body your body
also you get a headache your foot hurts
eventually you're gonna this is gonna
get [ __ ] bad eventually something's
gonna go so well this is worse than
trayvon martin because at least the guy
who killed trayvon martin was just an
idiot
neighborhood watch guy this guy's a cop
so my prayers go to the family and
everybody
my my prayers go to ferguson that uh you
know they got some [ __ ] sleep last
night and they didn't go out during the
curfew i was close to ferguson all
[ __ ] weekend i was two hours from for
i was 100 miles from st louis i was in
paducah kentucky i got to tell you man i
was [ __ ] blown away why what happened
it was just a different type of place it
was a lot different than what i
anticipated i did a comedy show at the
exoterra cafe you know the kid helped me
out uh
george mcshane uh just like a coffee
shop right it was just a coffee shop it
set 50 people
i went in there and i just talked and i
really had a [ __ ] great time just you
know you don't understand uh
comedy a lot of people don't understand
there's two different types of comedy
there's the open mic comedy and people
doing shows then there's the paid comedy
you know and sometimes you get sick and
tired of just doing paid comedy
you love just going in and then nobody
gives you any money he's just going with
no
there were no tickets no no oh okay
there was a tip jar and i told him at
the end to give it to the young comics
because
they drove and i i want them to feel
like to make 10 20 bucks to know that
this is working you know okay so i there
was a tip jar out and i said nobody i
don't want no money you know we're gonna
give it to these young guys that put the
show together
and that uh and so they they know that
they're on the right track that that's
always great when you're a comic and
somebody gives you 40 bucks or 50 bucks
it's a great [ __ ] feeling you know to
know that you're on the right track so
that's why i did it and i had a great
time you know lee and i were talking
about the baby how hard it is to travel
with a child i mean it almost pushed us
to a [ __ ] divorce saturday morning
that's how hard we got into an argument
because we hadn't slept in two nights
you know a child has a certain uh
what do you call that a schedule mm-hmm
and once you remove them from that
schedule a new surrounding [ __ ]
affects us how is it not gonna affect a
19 month old child you know yeah it's
amazing that this baby uh mercy talks
and runs and jumps in puddles and she's
hell on wheels but she's still a [ __ ]
baby she's not even in that mid-level
she's a baby she's still
her words are starting to come together
it's a beautiful to see
like she'll try to have a conversation
with me
and i'll get four or five words dude
this weekend the word was coming it was
come everything was come okay she turned
around you got to follow her
so now when i was calling him like come
and she would come to me you know so
it's getting easier but she's a baby
it's still hard she's a baby she [ __ ]
flipped on the flight on the way there
you know at the airport it's this big
area where all these people she wants to
run but she can't and you can't say
listen this is an airport we gotta come
down here but we'll run later and she
hasn't done this yeah you can't read the
second flight with this puddle [ __ ]
jumper
and she's sweating and she doesn't
understand and she's looking at me for
the answers and i ain't got him i don't
want to build this [ __ ] plan either
you know i don't want to be on this
[ __ ] plane either but i explained to
my wife so
you know temp is boiled there but i'm
happy just to be home
you know man i have five weeks at home
i'm having knee surgery next tuesday
and this was what these weeks were for
you know i'm not going to sacramento
with joe next week
because these weeks were already
anticipated for this knee surgery and
the rest and the rehab
i really want this knee to be done with
so i can really get this weight off me i
can really focus on
my you know and i'm really working hard
lately i've been uh
going to higan machado's jiu-jitsu
school i've already gone like three
weeks in a row you know i signed up for
the bjj uh
the the log okay i forget what it's
called right now uh my friends talked
about it raphy talked about it
and ever since i joined up that thing
it's helped me a lot more with uh jiu
jitsu and i'll tell you why because it's
the weight watchers concept it's being
responsible for everything when you have
a website that you have to go to every
day and report to and tell it what you
ate yeah yeah calories and all that [ __ ]
it really makes you a little bit more
you know i was going to bjj once or
twice a week now i've been going three
times a week ever since i joined that
wow because you put it in it tells you
if you're going to improve or not and
how much you improve by going that third
day and that you also write your
techniques down you know like what you
learned so a lot of times i was learning
something coming home and just
forgetting now i come home and it forces
me to write in the log you know if
anybody's on a if anybody's going to bjj
you're trying to lose weight or anything
like that that always helps when you log
stuff in of what you've done it's like
today i have to go to bjj at 11 but i
got to tell you something i got a full
[ __ ] day
i got auditions today i gotta put a tape
on audition on tape i gotta put
something down for comedy central i got
a meeting with these two dudes tonight
my day goes to seven o'clock wow but i
gotta tell you something man uh and you
brought it up to me i'm very lucky for
my cats oh yeah that was awesome my cats
uh
any animal it's not just my cats i was
just leaving the house now and i saw a
biggie outside
and the other blonde cat and i walked up
to big ears i put my stuff in the car
and i was letting it warm up you know up
you know and i lowered the windows and i
saw a biggie he's a cat in the
neighborhood
and i walked out and i said biggie big
and he walked over and just dropped and
let me pet him this morning biggie's a
big blond cat he's in one of the mad
flavors yeah he lives down the block for
me biggie's a bad [ __ ] biggie
was like the neighborhood pimp but then
they cut his balls off and now he's just
this mellow dude
and just this morning i was walking
upstairs and i was thinking about my
wife and the baby and
how you think about the troubles of the
world whatever the [ __ ] i was thinking
about just
and as i was walking the street to pet
biggie just me petting biggie this
morning just me playing with biggie for
five minutes because when you scratch
biggie's back he goes
he owes his mouth but then it comes out
it's like he's lip-syncing like a
japanese movie just that little rub is
back for five minutes yeah gave me so
much satisfaction oh yeah and uh you
mentioned it yesterday when you called
back that you know i had we watched the
cats at night i have the lady come in
the daytime feed them clean the litter
boxes
and i know my cats i know they're very
uh social
so i have you stopping you like them
they like you you know yeah you stop in
you feed them you sit there for 10
minutes and you uh
you know tell them whatever that you
love them or whatever the [ __ ] you tell
them and
you know you even said it that you got
something out of it it was it was cool
and i walked in
like they all they were they were
looking at me
and i took a couple pictures because
they were just so cute but then you told
me to go feed him and then i got on the
phone because i didn't like there's
different places for the bowls and i'm
sure i didn't even get it right
but then you're like put a wet can and
even before as soon as i went into the
kitchen like they all came out of the
woodwork and like they were gray meow's
non-stop which i didn't i didn't expect
and then uh jimmy was going crazy too
and it was cool to watch because they
must have been hungry
two nights ago because as soon as i put
the food down they all went in there and
then i was like sitting on the couch
like by myself in your living room
watching espn i'm like what am i doing
here but then they all came out and
started like washing themselves and and
uh cece came over
and and harry and jimmy always come over
and it's just it's uh
i wish i had more time and and and for
cats i i'm i probably could do it but uh
i i always i always enjoy just playing
with the cats
like anytime you
you're having a [ __ ] up day or
whatever you walk home and
whatever whether you have a dog or a cat
you go over you pet your dog you feed
them and then you're gonna go do
something and for some reason you feel
so bad you drop the one knee
and you just look at him and hug him and
play with him and grab his ear and maybe
get a ball and throw for your dog
those three minutes uh you know they say
when you have an animal you live longer
people who have dogs and cats live a
little longer you know and i'm and i can
guarantee it's those moments like
yesterday i got home and i tell me
i was [ __ ] tired i was tired
physically i was tired mentally you know
uh
the night before i hadn't slept friday
night so i get there thursday we go to
dinner you know we go back to the room
i'm watching tv i think it's going to be
a regular night you know me i go to bed
at 11 30. next you know at 4 a.m i'm
walking around i mean i got up i could
not sleep i couldn't the baby was next
to me on the bed you know she woke up i
i played with i went and got breakfast
and the day started
friday night
i went to do that coffee shop and i
didn't eat a cheap or chew i had a
cheaper chew for the whole weekend okay
and i said i'm not gonna eat it friday
man i should have eaten it friday night
because i got back to the room and it
was a [ __ ] nightmare and by four in
the morning we were just fighting and
she left at seven because the child just
wouldn't sleep there you know
she went to her brother's house and the
baby slept there and then when she got
back we put the baby down again
but uh
so i went to bed at saturday night like
at eight o'clock i had to catch a 6 a.m
flight in paducah which the airport is
hilarious [ __ ] the best airport that
in santa fe new mexico this didn't even
have a food santa fe had a restaurant
this didn't even have a restaurant this
just had four machines
it had one like where did you get for
your egg sandwich machine oh no a coffee
machine
a candy machine and a soda machine
that's all this place had excuse me
i didn't have nobody serving hot food
nothing i was prepared i had like a
banana
and something else you know and by the
time i got home that chicago la flight
was easy i saw ron futch
on the plane okay talk to him at the
airport in chicago i met him
i shook his hand as i was eating a
friday
chicago was [ __ ] starving
and uh i got home and i tell you
when i walked in the house i had to do a
couple how to clean the litter box and
sweep up a little bit
i open the door to get some air in there
i lit some candles i [ __ ] uh just to
give them my through all the clothes and
the tan you know i do my regular ship
hook up the sleep batman machine and i
had this list i had to go to routes i
had to go to the bank i had to go to the
weed store i had to make another move at
this place i had to stop and see if the
medication was in from my [ __ ] knee
and i tell you what when i got back last
night i really wanted to take you to
dinner
take leave it then after i do the emails
i couldn't leave the house oh i knew
that cause you asked me what you're
doing for dinner i'm like i'm gonna have
it in a little bit and you really i you
i knew you were tired i was tired but i
just felt bad for them i didn't want to
leave them another night right so i
basically got on my hands and knees like
at 4 30 with them and i brushed all of
them which was a [ __ ] amazing
to brush those cats with the metal thing
and then with the brush to get the hair
off do they like line up at all or oh my
god they [ __ ] love it and they
scratch at each other to move you you're
done don't come back
[ __ ] you he already brushed you i got so
worried and i wasn't even high but i got
worried because you have baby things set
up in your house
and i'm not i'm not that experienced
with cats so cece got behind the one on
the tv place
and i was like i don't know if she can
get back out from there so like i may i
like kept calling her like i wanted her
to just be out of there when i before i
left but then she jumped and i'm like oh
that's not for the cat that's for that's
just so mercy doesn't get behind there
and the cats are fine but i was ta i was
i was i was my worst nightmare was like
that i was gonna leave saturday night
and you would get back sunday afternoon
in mercy and cece would be behind there
like meow i can peed somewhere she
wasn't supposed to behind the tv and
but she was fine
no mercy uh
they always go back there okay i didn't
know
you know they gotta break my balls some
[ __ ] part of the
other day and they go back there and
they they love it you know
when the kid's not there they don't
really uh piss back there or anything or
shed i thought she was gonna get trapped
no but it's just really nice to uh
have them it's really nice to have
animals and just to take time yesterday
as stressed out as i was i sat them all
down like i said i pat them and demi-bit
me
while i'm brushing them they get so
emotional when you brush them like the
girls put their claws in here as you
brush oh yeah and they bite your hand
and demi bites you a little bit he'll
bite your wrist a little bit as you're
brushing his ears it's pretty
interesting [ __ ] but it's
i don't know it's just a great [ __ ]
yeah where's the music i wish i want to
be around this monday [ __ ] get
your [ __ ] together
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
get up
grab your ball sniff your fingers thank
the lord for giving you another [ __ ]
day [ __ ] the church [ __ ]
this candy's kicking in
oh [ __ ] yeah
i'm pretty mellow
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
i thought of you last night because
there's this app that you can get like
discount tickets on and i was just
looking through the board because i
couldn't fall asleep and
wu-tang clan with talib collies going to
the forum in englewood and i was like
would that be cool to go see and then i
just thought of you like why are you
gonna go jump up and down with all the
black people
don't
the forum just it's beautiful they said
that we did it inside you know i went to
see janet jackson there really in like
98 they said they redid and stuff let me
ask what is going on with the ice
challenge
i don't understand what else is i don't
understand nothing well that's not my
buddy
they're [ __ ] just you're getting
challenged left them i was gonna
challenge you but just it's it's lou
gehrig's disease okay uh which is
terrible i saw the thing they did on
support center but like it just it just
shuts you down like your brain's still
good but you're you can't move and you
can't talk and your body just
disintegrates
uh
and this guy who got it when he was like
27 a baseball player who was great and
he just he started raising awareness for
it and it's just
people are doing it now just to do the
ice and i
just i i only did for the ice i don't
have money right now to be donating to
people but the point is is you're
supposed to raise awareness for the
disease because what he said is is
apparently it hasn't changed since lou
gehrig got it like there's been no
improvements it just when you get it
you're it's just like two years and
you're dead
um so they said like
their
the als foundation's donations have gone
up like 400 percent
from this time last year which is great
some people get annoyed because it's
just people on facebook now and it's
just it's like a celebrity status symbol
now to be to be doing it i do
i think i think
it's good that people are getting
awareness and it's good to bring people
together and it's always it's a funny
way to do it because people it's cold in
the ice
but i do see what some people are saying
like why don't you just donate the money
don't put a video on facebook and i
understand that part of it but i
i got challenged so i did it and
i uh
i was gonna nominate you but i was like
there's no way you're gonna stand on
your front lawn in a bathing suit and
pour ice water on your head
you never know yeah
if it's for a good cause and uh maybe
i'll write a check 50 bucks 100 you know
you never know yeah i mean it's all
about it's scary i mean my
my
grandmother didn't have als but she had
alzheimer's
which is basically the same and that's
genetics and i'm worried about my mom
and uh seth rogen had that thing a few
months ago where he went in front of uh
someone in congress and was talking
about it and it's just
that's really like that's one of the
ones where like this kid was healthy
like
i'm i'm trying to get healthier now
and there's just some stuff no matter
how healthy you get
like you have a bad roll of the genetic
cards or something but we have a call
come in
what's up danny b
oh you're telling me brother man how's
everything good good no last night i'm
sitting there minding my own [ __ ]
business going through the channels
and i'm watching carolina play somebody
last night and i'm sitting there going
it's amazing that it's [ __ ] football
season again
and usually i just watch it for a minute
i watch the quarter in fact i call lee
and i go lead i'm sitting here watching
football because i can't i go yeah i'm
scratching the [ __ ] itch you know
know you get sick and tired of not
having football on and i listen man i
always started as a football fan but as
life gets real
you got to cut the fantasy [ __ ] out so i
cut away from football i can't sit there
anymore danny and watch three games like
we used to
30 years ago on a sunday i wish i could
i wish i could well you know what cuz
you got you got responsibility now back
in the day we had none and i get it for
me it comes natural because it's part of
what i do but for the average guy
you know unless they're betting the game
those guys can't help themselves but
yeah i get it it's tough to sit down as
you get older watching a
football or a baseball game in its
entirety i'm a peaker i peak man like i
don't even like to see this [ __ ] go
cause i got money on a game i peek at it
i come back 10 minutes later i peek
because i'll tell you why
i had the colts the other night 26
to nothing over the giants with 10
minutes left in the game they lost 27 to
26. do they really that's why you know
yeah it [ __ ] killed me man i was
looking at the score i didn't watch the
game i got right
26 [ __ ] nothing 10 minutes left in
the game i wake up the next day i saw
the final score i almost puked my
breakfast up that's why these games [ __ ]
you up man but yeah it is good to have
football here
but reality yeah it's tough to watch a
full football game let me ask you
something i was talking about lee last
night and we like i go lee you're not
watching because i don't watch
pre-season night and i go you know it's
amazing that people are betting right
now already he goes home and i broke it
down for like only you know most people
right now like north bergen people
people grew up with um like last night
they better five times a 25 bucks maybe
a five-time paul way
50 bucks to watch the game and to them
that's what they're doing it's a reason
to watch the game
you don't have everybody gambling but
you gotta well listen i'll tell you why
i'll tell you what there's some sick
bastards out there i got a client that
rock and rolls you don't care i'm
talking about that that's 500 on the
game but he can't do it so he's betting
three grand a game on pre-season games
oh my god now so
yeah yeah you know you have to have a
transaction baby but how action is
actually so when when when gamblers when
good gamblers are breaking down games
i'm like they're looking at who's
playing but with preseason they're
bringing in people who aren't even gonna
make the team like that
well yeah yeah good point here's the
thing with preseason a lot of people say
you're crazy playing it you put certain
teams have a different itinerary you
know they're checking out defensive
backs they know who's doing what look
for a team with depth like quarterbacks
fighting for each other you know
fighting for the number one spot look
what pete carroll did in seattle game he
had uh russell wilson in with like two
minutes left in the first half he almost
got hurt too so he's playing to win he
ain't [ __ ] around so pre-season for
the average guy yet back to [ __ ] off but
guys that have the edge you know you
follow the money that's simple for me i
just follow the sharp guys and
you know they make money more times than
they loosely that's simple but yeah back
off the preseason because it is a crap
shoot you know it's amazing i've been i
look at the twitter timelines
from time to time i see you hustling
i see the philly godfather hustling but
i see a couple new people on the horizon
that are getting retweeted by people
that are on the computer it's amazing
how much this how much life changes but
it's really amazing how the trends
change danny you know 20 years ago you
have to call people all [ __ ] day
now they're on the computer they're on
the [ __ ] computer figuring it out and
you could sell your product on the
computer without even talking to the
person
well the problem is you can do that but
a lot of guys ain't qualified to sell a
product so anybody with a website and a
twitter account is making money you know
because you know most guys are okay at
it but push comes to shove this this
ain't easy when you're betting your own
money and how many of those guys are
actually betting their own money that's
the thing
are they really betting or are they
selling pits because you know they got
nothing to lose you know so
you know become a dime a dozen these
days i'm scratching my head you know i'm
scratching my head you know every time i
turn around there's and but there's some
legitimate guys out there i get them on
podcast a couple of real sharp players
out there but they're far and few
between brother
um what else did i want to say yeah i
hear you were in kentucky or tennessee
not too long ago this was again this
last weekend man
how did that go for you
kentucky's a listen man
i practice what i preach i'm not going
to come on this [ __ ] podcast and tell
you [ __ ] that i love smallville
usa i love visiting smallville usa
i do it more than most of the people i
know i love
that small mentality i love going to see
people and their most primitive effect
you know anybody can go to chicago
anybody could go to new york go do
comedy and paducah
you know at a coffee shop you know with
60 people who drove from louisville
kentucky to see you
four hours people drove from cincinnati
it was a great feeling man and uh i like
being in the heartlands of places you
know anybody could go to north bergen
you know go to the middle of new jersey
go to the middle of new jersey where
there's [ __ ] mountain lions and [ __ ]
and you have a conversation with them i
remember when the shore was different
even when the shore was just
you know i always felt bad for the short
people because for four months a year
they got tormented they got tormented by
[ __ ] like me
and [ __ ] damn rego and [ __ ] you
know for four months and i remember when
frankie edgar first came on the scene in
the ufc he started beating people one of
the first bets i haven't made in the ufc
with my wife on the was ufc 100 was
frankie edgar when he beat sean shirk
and nobody could believe it and i
remember telling joe rogan on the way
back i go
i grew up down there those kids
were forced to be tough
those little short [ __ ] those
little dirty dogs as i used to call them
those dudes would fight you to the death
down there
yeah they were tough you know we had
some good times on that you're right we
tormented that town wherever belmore
seaside we picked a new city every year
well no you evolved you started that you
first started at seaside live all right
and then you went to belmore and then
you went to manasquan
and then you went to the other shores
what was that place uh in uh belmont
that we used to that the roof is on fire
placement remember that song what the
[ __ ] was that there was one place
montego bay where we were eating queen
luke's like
montego bay dude i remember many times
waking up in the parking lot at like 10
in the morning the owner kicked me like
hey dan we're getting ready to open the
club you mind moving over yeah no no
like what i had rocks in my face on the
little spoon we had some good times
though a lot a lot of a lot of laughs
10 10 people piling up in a one bedroom
you know just bodies everywhere people
know that they charge you everywhere
they would charge you a lot of money for
those houses in the summer the landlords
would jack the prices up so you couldn't
afford them so you had to go like eight
people to a house but it's amazing when
i see pictures now the show like i have
people send me pictures of what the
beach looks like on the weekend first of
all they haven't really recovered from
the hurricane sandy yeah have not
recovered a lot of those shores are
still closed construction you know they
got hit you know like when uh when when
the hail comes down in colorado next
thing you know every construction
companies in colorado
not only that you have all the fake
contractors that come take your deposit
and they never do the work they'll tell
you yeah give us 10 up front we'll be
here in a month because we're [ __ ]
busy as [ __ ]
and they'll never do the work well that
also happened in new jersey because new
jersey being the capital of [ __ ]
scams they got scammed the hardest so a
lot of these people went back to do
construction and those places they
[ __ ] done yet so the shore this is no
my mother
dad i'm sorry
the show
there i go again here i go we're so
[ __ ] rude to where we're from
that week was very uh
tough so i don't even know i lost my
train of thought there what were you
saying about me i did it to you i [ __ ]
you up i i [ __ ] you up take a bite of
the brownie it'll come to you no my
mother lives in uh keansburg you know
and that's a short town and they're
still [ __ ] up half of the block is is
uh when they condemned they got it roped
up they haven't recovered and what are
we two years later
or more so that place is [ __ ] up i
haven't really hit the jersey shore a
couple of years back
in seaside the book the rooms were
booked we found one place we saw a ghost
and we left i got a picture of it i'm
going to send it to you legitimately
jamie was taking a picture of me and the
kids slumming it we called slumming it
because we're always in these five-star
hotels
we couldn't find nothing but a hole in
the wall so we're laying in this broken
down victorian building and i said jamie
take a picture of this i've never done
this in a long time
and then we were talking about packing
up and leaving and then she goes you
might really want to pack up now look
and we found a ghost in the picture i
put it all over facebook i got to get it
out there if anybody out there any of
you fans out there don't tell me that's
a ghost i'm telling you coco it was a
[ __ ] ghost i gotta send you to pedro
you'll trip out on it so that's the last
time i went to new jersey uh new jersey
beaches besides atlantic city last time
i was new jersey beach
was probably nine years ago and i didn't
even go to the beach i was with jimmy
burkel
jimmy
oh [ __ ] name from the desk uh and we
went to atlantic city to eat crab legs
and while i was in atlantic city i got a
gig
in connecticut
so jimmy berkeley and me got in the car
he drove me all the way to connecticut
but as far as swimming down the shore
oh my god it's got to be 98
97 i used to go to seaside park with the
delorenzos or chris
and on the corner he had a hot dog stand
oh my god danny they had spicy green
they had spicy chili the guy had the
[ __ ] uh the sabret chili but he
spiced it up and i would get like six i
would get six hot dogs a city i was
averaging [ __ ] 20 hot dogs a day
three days down this shore it was
amazing i was [ __ ] you know what
you mentioned be lorenzo that he had
that place a little unit next to the
montego bay remember that apartment
complex right by montgomery yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was awesome where i used
to sleep in the parking lot you know
there was no room
you know if you got in early you got a
bed or a spot on the floor but half the
time i would grab a blanket [ __ ]
sleep right in the park a lot of montego
bay
you know and uh oh those were good times
and that's funny too i also remember
that we missed taser of course romano
she was like one of the boys she [ __ ]
blast blow all night long act like
nothing happened arm wrestle yet
she went tubing in the [ __ ] atlantic
and she forgot to shave
her you know a little choochie and i
just remember looking at it was like the
funniest thing she just floated around
all [ __ ] up with a hairy [ __ ]
sticking out
but uh yeah we had some good times back
then coco how's your birthday now
huh what do you hear from gary
i just got snob bad and bad stuff okay
let me patent out the gary story here um
i got a link sent to me
about a week ago from my cousin mikey
i guess the kid that he he
robbed the banquet flipped and confessed
on other things he was on a spree there
you know a three-week spree all in north
bergen right he's [ __ ] a three mile
mile radius he took down first the guy
they got him for the one bank
carjacking blah blah blah but the young
kid fessed up today i've robbed a bank
earlier in the week uh like four days
earlier they had done a couple of
mcdonald's and burger kings and
there was a restaurant down there the
chateau remember the chateau coco uh
it's still there i think that's the name
of it they followed some broad home
gunpoint took like six large from uh
from her from her purse
so they connect and he's done bro he's
not gonna see the the streets again
you know enough
so that's the latest i haven't spoke to
him you know i think he's
in newark somewhere around north prison
i'm not sure he hasn't wrote to nobody
but yeah we just got the latest charges
so
yeah you know so he did a few banks and
god only knows what else he did and uh
and one of the getaway drivers died
that's right i i forgot it wouldn't tell
in the story but they had a getaway
driver that died i don't think it was
related to the bank robbery so
gary's [ __ ] uh i don't know it's sad
bro it said it's killing my mom
you know she's uh
she's not doing too well herself but
yeah he ain't gonna come home anytime
soon pal what what's the deal for the
season what do you got for these guys if
they sign up now
whether it's for the month whether it's
for the year
what do you got going on this year
what's the package well let's see what
we got today for the church guys i
always take care of something special
but for the common guy out there we got
the
150 for the month but if you sign up for
one month you get another month free
breaks down to like less than five
dollars at play and then if you do it
for the year it's like 50 cents a play
we give out like 30 to 40 plays a month
if you break down the math it breaks
down to dollars or pennies
i'm not really you know really right now
we're getting ready to get the football
season on off as you know my bread and
butt is still radio we just did me and
big lou just did a uh
uh what did they call a documentary on
sports betting with uh with the national
geographic channel
they were out by you guys in california
for drag racing you know how people bet
on the car races on the street
then they were down in uh georgia doing
dog and [ __ ] fighting
so they came up this way to do me and
luke was for sports betting so that
that'll shoot here sometime in january
we're just getting ready to get my
season uh going coco you know this week
next thursday
starts it up the 28th
but tonight you have a big game with uh
cleveland and walk they're anticipating
a big audience tonight for this
johnny football you know he's not
starting but
tonight's a big game they expect a good
uh good audience to watch the monday
night game
what's you know man whatever happened to
monday night football when i was growing
up monday night was everything you
didn't even make plans on monday night
if you did an event on monday night you
were [ __ ] because why would you do
something people gonna keep asking hey
is the game on you just get irritated
now monday night football is nothing
it's like [ __ ] nobody even
acknowledges it there's no more happy
hours there's nobody [ __ ] stabbing
people
you know you used to know they got it
they got it going on here they do kind
of big i don't know about out west but
here they still got their monday night
specials wing nights they celebrate but
you're right the lust is gone it's not
what it what nothing is nothing is
everything's televised there's games
seven days a week you know but when
we're in the 80s we had that build up we
had that monday night build up they
didn't even have the sunday night when
we were out there every once in a while
they would have an espn special sunday
night evening atlanta falcons or
something but no it was straight up uh
lee what's going on you want to ask
danny a question you're over there you
stoned it on that candy i'm a little
awesome but i i have a bunch of
questions we'll hit them what the [ __ ]
fired away well uh joey i don't remember
why we were talking about it
uh you guys are [ __ ] stoned all the
time yeah we're [ __ ] stoned all the
time that's why you forget [ __ ] that's
true but we were he was talking he was
saying how if we went to atlantic city
you can't leave the strip and i i
i really like gambling i'm just not i
haven't put enough time into it to be
good at it and i was watching this
documentary
on this blackjack player who beat like
the
the atlantic uh because atlantic city
casinos for like 50 million dollars come
on spit it out it's okay he beat him for
like 15 million but uh they were saying
that atlantic city is literally dying
right now
so like it's deadly and you were saying
you were just there so like why is it
like why is it dying
well you know what a couple of things i
ain't the ghetto
i was at the rebel which is i think just
went out of business or about and it's
the most beautiful casino it's the most
expensive casino in the united states at
2 billion
it's gorgeous it's got it's gone
bankrupt twice now in less than two
years
uh there's there's no reason to go there
you have casinos here in uh bethlehem
the sands they're all over philly and
the poconos and yonkers so there's no
reason you can bet online now in new
jersey uh there's no reason to go to
atlantic city yeah it's beachfront
but it's panhandlers it's
it's lost its luster sports betting
could help
help the road to recovery but it's not
the the solution
you know it's not the whole solution but
it definitely can help
spice up some interest
uh you things have just changed you know
what again when they were the one uh
game in town yeah everybody went to
atlantic city but you don't have to know
more lake
you know what they come that they come
up with this rebel
it's gorgeous
it's an oasis in atlantic city but it
wasn't
people friendly they didn't have it
they designed it beautiful but not for
gambling they kind of made it like a
resort
and people down here they're broke they
don't have money to spend like that and
it just wasn't uh
carefully thought out the layout of the
place but a beautiful uh they tried to
put a silk hat on a pig that's what
happened they tried to put a silk on a
[ __ ] pig you know first off let's get
you're absolutely right me and lee just
went lee and i just went down to
harris in san diego the casino we went
down there lee how good was the lobster
bisque great everything was great it's a
beautiful [ __ ] place so me and leah
coming back with stone to the gills on a
cookie and we're talking about how
a gambler a degenerate gambler
doesn't need to go to las vegas anymore
all he has to do is drive to san diego
now or pechanga casino or the bicycle
club which rock all day right in my
neighborhood here right off the 7 10
after gabriel glacier started calmly at
the bicycle
casino you go to commerce casino the
same thing okay they're all [ __ ] thai
and asian people but who gives a [ __ ]
they got cash
that all cuts out from vegas
vegas is going after the 21 year old
that drives every friday and does
ecstasy and jumps up and down vegas
isn't doing bad
they're not doing well like okay so now
in vegas you got these 21 and 23 year
olds that go to do drugs and you got
families
that in between is missing that in
between is staying home
that in between is saying hey you know
what i don't need to spend 600 hours on
a [ __ ] plane ticket and another four
in a hotel room to gamble i could pocket
that i could buy an eight ball and save
700.
no well said well said and again here i
mean i got the sands hopefully you'll
get a chance to play there it's
beautiful i mean it's a probably one of
the nicest casinos i've seen
the rooms are reasonable but the problem
there now is they they're busting in all
the gooks out of new york's just the the
you know the asians are coming in
they're giving them like three uh fifty
dollars worth to play
they got a guy they did a little film on
him he makes two trips a day
he gets these fifty dollar vouchers
sells them for forty bucks
so he makes eighty bucks a day just
going back and forth hanging out you
walk around the sands it's like night of
the living dead nothing but asians just
walking around waiting for the bus to
take them back
they take baths in in the bathrooms
they steal your little uh freak plays
your cards you know your [ __ ] card
you leaving the machine it's really
bizarre
so yeah both atlantic city and las vegas
it'll never be what was
there's too many places popping up but
you know with a little help from uh
legislature if they legalize sports
betting in atlantic city because it is
beachfront you know it is that's one
advantage they have that vegas doesn't
and speech front the beaches are pretty
nice i heard the beaches nice i heard
the beaches clean i have a friend that's
very picky and he says that he found the
solution he goes to atlantic city
because nobody goes on that beach in the
summer because they're all down the
shore jumping up and down he goes you go
to atlantic city he goes you get a room
you go on the beach it's like stealing
he doesn't even gamble no he goes down
there he gets a steak and he comes back
on sunday he loves it him and his wife
[ __ ] love it
nobody knows yeah they don't gamble
but nobody remembers
nobody remembers d when we were growing
up if you went to 30th street and bergen
line avenue by the cab stand you paid
9.99
they gave you a voucher they gave you 10
quarters
and they gave you 20 000 coupons to eat
and they put you on a bus to atlantic
city the catch was you couldn't leave
early if you lost so if you took the 7
a.m bus you had to take you gotta wait
for the three o'clock bus you couldn't
go back on the 11 o'clock bus that's how
they got you to spend money because they
know you're gonna lose they're gonna
give it was free atlantic city basically
bust you for free because it cost you
ten to get in but you got ten thousand
quarters when you got down there
uh okay yeah
well that's what they're doing with the
with the asians but they're disciplined
they're [ __ ] smooth you know they're
they're disciplined they can walk around
they graze
i'm telling you you'll see them you're
like what the [ __ ] is this they're all
over the place so how far is it from new
york to bethlehem by bus
oh [ __ ] without traffic hour 15 from the
port authority daddy being cool that's
[ __ ] amazing
no so i'm telling you they're making
money it's like they were all over the
local news here like how the asians are
just taking the free and they're making
a profit they're making they're giving
them fifty dollars in vouchers
they're selling them for forty to the
guys you know so the guy saving ten
bucks
he do a couple of times a day they
travel five days a week the guy's making
400 bucks they find you know again
they pack their little lunches once in a
while
it's [ __ ] amazing but they also come
in connecticut they got all these places
around new york now that you don't need
you know and and i love las vegas i got
nothing against las vegas
but again a degenerate gambler in this
economy
[ __ ] you know it's tough out there
for a pimp i don't need to go to vegas
to play cards at the blackjack
convention when i could go to bethlehem
get [ __ ] i'm an hour from my house
if i pick up a chick and i want to stab
her
what happened hey listen i i was up in
long island man you know the comical up
in long island you've done comedy up
there a few times but i have a little
office up we moved from comac to
bayshore my boy lives in port jeff port
jefferson so they got all of these
[ __ ] italians coming in playing
high-end cards it was [ __ ] i wish i was
filming a coco it was the most
hysterical thing
i've seen these guys were having pots of
30 40 000
i was tripping out i went to bed at 12
o'clock i woke up for work they were
still at it at nine o'clock they stayed
in the place till like 12 or 1 o'clock
uh but just the atmosphere was funny you
ever want some of those long island guys
coco
when they're playing cursing and making
fun of each other
so yeah it was kind of comical but you
don't have to go nowhere you don't have
to go far or you can bet online right
now
you know especially in new jersey nevada
you don't you can bet legally online and
there's 90 percent of us out there that
are betting illegally online isn't there
a casino in new york city in like queens
dockers yeah
yeah it's a good one you got the
racetrack there you know so it's a nice
setting
uh it was one of the first casinos that
offered full service
they started off with slot machines only
and then they instituted blackjack
roulette and poker
but yonkers i believe was the first
allegedly mama's park is going to offer
sports betting and they're going to
ignore the federal band so let's see
what happens here in the next couple of
weeks let's see if the feds it's kind of
like the popping you know it's illegal
federally but in the states it varies so
same with uh mammoth park they're just
saying [ __ ] it
we're going to stick our chests out and
see what happens i wonder if the feds
will come in and confiscate the machines
or
or whatever i don't know so
that should happen in two weeks they're
saying my mother's number one addiction
was the ponies
and that was her last hope was yonkers
because that was nighttime
they were late night like when she
called me at midnight i knew she was
coming back from [ __ ] yonkers
yonka's is the last planet unknown the
last stop that [ __ ] track looked like
death at night
i used to be scared she was telling me
she was going to yonkers
because it was every degenerate in the
tri-state area this is their last hope
the wake-up of money in their pocket
and they redid the track i hope they
[ __ ] redid that thing oh it's nice
they did some urban organizations there
because that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] jungle
up there that was
that was this and you know what man you
have to uh that's the other thing though
these casinos
look great they look great for the eye
and they get a stake in there you get a
good cheap stake in there for these
[ __ ] people and they feel like they
had a [ __ ] the palms hotel
and they're ready to go i don't blame
them i don't blame an atlantic city i'll
tell you i've been to atlantic city i
could put it on my hand
and it was it's been like an okay
experience all five times
let me tell you something the food's not
good no more remember they used to feed
you for free even in vegas the food was
next to nothing vegas still offers a lot
of great food but you're paying for it
in the 80s we ate like kings uh it's
expensive we got
bethlehem i mean without traffic it's
literally eight minutes from my house
the uh bethlehem uh the stands they got
emeralds in there the food's okay but
it's [ __ ] expensive
you know you figure you can't eat sheep
in these places no more
you know so you know gambling's huge man
it's everywhere i just don't
you know i just don't see why they don't
let us bet on the sports because
everybody wants to do it and everybody's
doing it you know uh
people are getting in trouble because
they have to i think here's my opinion
if you if you're regular regulated
make people post money that they can
afford to lose rather than betting with
bookies on credit and stuff like that i
think it's just good it's just smart but
let's see what happens and football
again officially next thursday college
football starts up
some teams to look for let me throw out
a little advice you can look at some of
these uh future bets okay let me get to
it are you okay over there you [ __ ] up
yeah i'm [ __ ] up when i'm listening
it's not a bad game you're ready you're
ready yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm ready i
said now these odds have been changing a
lot of guys are going to be playing the
favorites like seattle and patriots in
denver you know you got seattle nine to
two and denver like seven to one
patriots i'm looking at some value here
you know long shots to an extent but
good teams like the saints if you put
some money on the saints you can get
them at 20 to 1.
they have a good chance of winning the
super bowl this year so i'm liking the
saints
at 20 to 1 and in uh afc the colts bring
a lot of value at 25 to 1. so if you put
a little bit of money on these teams
maybe 10 bucks 20 bucks
and then you see that they're not
cutting it towards the end of the year
you can always hedge your bet but some
some good value on the saints cults and
in college football
a lot of people are high on oklahoma
sooners this year you know they started
off at 15 to one
now they're at ten to one so they're
high on them
of course your florida state bama all
burner flavor favorites uh but georgia
some people like georgia at 13th one in
oregon
at my personal bet is uh south carolina
i think south carolina and spuria
long shot at 23-1 but
there's some definitely some good value
out there lee anybody have any uh
thoughts well
it's not anybody it's not nfl but before
lebron james went to the cavaliers like
how many people are going to make
millions if they win because weren't
they like 60 to one before lebron james
came another like now they're like the
favorites
so like that that always i always feel
stupid because when like when that first
came out it was like the cavaliers were
like 60 to 1 odds and now they're like
five to one so if if they win some
people are going to make millions
well yeah i mean if you got in early
before the move yeah that was [ __ ]
great but you know
you got to see the future there but
honestly i was surprised that he went
back there but
you know good for him you know they
hated him a few years ago now they love
him again that's the world you know what
what have you done for me lately
you know but again anything can happen i
just hate this year and this i've been
doing this now this is my 21st season
like doing radio and television with
this [ __ ] and
it's every year it's something different
you know always something happens
somebody gets hurt and [ __ ] up the team
so i always tell everybody and i'm
honest with everybody but
just put some money aside that you can
afford to lose have some fun with this
expect
you know expect some ups and downs but
you know you can make money at this but
the key here lee you have to have money
you have to have money to go with this
like anything else
you tell people all the time and i'm
very clear about this coke you know the
way it is you got a hundred thousand
dollars put into a money market account
or or any investment what are you
looking at two percent seven percent
maybe if you're lucky so so on a low end
a money market account two
two percent of 100 large that's two
thousand dollars you pay taxes on it at
least enough for a [ __ ] happy meal
how much money did the government or the
banks make offer you a hundred grand
god only knows so for those guys that
have money that have discipline it ain't
for everybody i'm telling you why with
that type of money you can't get hurt
unless you get stupid
and bet ten thousand a game if you're
moving a thousand two thousand three
thousand a game with that type of money
behind you you're guaranteed to make
money as long as you stay disciplined
when i'm following guys that like the
philly godfather and the whole group one
thing about me now i'm more connected
than i've ever been coco
because now i'm tracking some real sharp
players all those guys you've had them
on your show the guys that were betting
the big money behind donaghy's uh games
you know and they're very sharp you know
people think you have to hit 80 70 to
make money
you don't
listen and i throw this out to everybody
too it's common sense people are looking
when they call me can i get 70
i could lie to you and say yeah but no
listen if you can hit 58
you had a great year
you had a great year and i'll just throw
out some numbers and i'm gonna round
them off on radio here
say 60 it's easy to follow rightly this
this goes to you please okay you have
you play 500 games in a year
okay and if you're in a position to say
or whatever you can afford you bet a
thousand dollars a game that's it people
try to get five thousand ten thousand
and they get greedy but if you bet
consistently and you hit sixty percent
that's three hundred lists and two
hundred losses at thousand dollars you
made three hundred thousand
you lost
and twenty thousand dollars with the
juice you still made eighty thousand
dollars just betting a thousand dollars
a game but it's not for everybody only
two percent of the people have the moxie
to do that
and they they don't chase you know coco
we know about the chase and i've seen
this i've made millions at this [ __ ]
honestly and i've lost millions too but
it's this is not for everybody it's not
for the squeamish it's not for the
compulsive guy the guy that has
addictive personalities this [ __ ] will
swallow you up i talked to guys that
paid service after service and they
always come back for more i'd be talking
to him i'm like so why whoa the guy
started off good for me or he he won his
first seven out of eight games then he
told me about a big game
about a couple of players that got food
poisoning and fighting with the
girlfriend and one big cocaine last
night so this game's a lock and i say
and
you bet it all yeah i did
well whose [ __ ] fault is that you
idiot you [ __ ] bet everything you
made on one game so
i've heard it all
this is [ __ ] no different than any
other addiction
worse actually because you can
wipe out everything that you've made in
your whole life in a matter of three
hours drug addicts alcoholics they take
time before they kill themselves
gamblers are [ __ ] worse than any
addict out there
take that to the bank where these people
find you danny b whoa in allentown 266
south 33rd street i have two missing
enough you can go to danny wins for you
dot com call danny wins4you.com
uh check it out you know pretty simple i
got some podcasts up there and a radio
show and i got big blue before you cut
me off i got big lou issa
you've never met him coco i don't think
have you met big blue no no but joey and
you have told me stories about yeah
and you know how big blue got ahold of
me because he heard me
on this podcast well his friend
it's november i just got done doing one
of the church shows with you we're
talking about how we used to take down
the drug dealers with big low so i see
his name show up on my caller id well
turns out his buddy's a fan in new
jersey
he hears us name dropping big blue he
says hey lou some well guys have been
talking about you robbing drug dealers
and stuff and
so it turned out that he called me and
we started reuniting and he's a boxing
promoter you know he's out there on show
box showtime he's got a bunch of boxes
out there
uh so yeah we've reunited and he's got
some good resources too he's good with
the boxing very good with boxing mma and
soccer so yeah you'll see a little bio
of big blue up there and it's not much
my website called like i keep it simple
bro i keep it very simple i will see you
in new york september 26th and 7th get
ready to eat some [ __ ] edibles and
your eyeballs are going to get ready oh
no no no i won't do it no more last time
i was paralyzed it was [ __ ] i told
you my [ __ ] eyes i went into a coma
my eyes were bleeding people from the
church were kind of trying to talk to me
and i'm like get the [ __ ] away from me
i love you guys
i love you too
man
thanks for having me
go get him everybody out there man uh
thanks for tuning in coach thanks for
having me danny b wins don't [ __ ] around
i love you [ __ ]
i love you too brother see you soon pal
bye-bye stay black see so if you're
gonna start your gambling this year just
get a little coach a little help i'm not
saying to go overboard if you uh but if
you want to try it i offer this to you
so you just uh
you know a hypothesis is an educated
[ __ ] guess
that's all sports betting is sometimes
an educated guess you know i'm saying
lee yeah how cute and stoned are you
right now you just said it's okay i'm
it's my own but
these are very nice let me give some
shout outs we got to talk about some
[ __ ] here my main man
mike trez
uh this is a special shout out sherman
jones for hooking us up with heat hit e6
luke denton i love you [ __ ] jesse
fontaine
greg fuentes
abel bernal and moses vasquez i love you
[ __ ] some shout outs uh
you know i love when we have the late
night guests you know i love them it's a
different uh
avenue of opportunity for you people i
really love that you guys i get to lee
and i get to [ __ ] bring different
people in here and but they also people
didn't ever hit me up and go joe you
haven't given us your take or lease take
on what's been going on and i really
wanted to get this out there today
because my buddy dean lapreet that i
grew up with who listened to the podcast
called me last week and we had a good
discussion about this and we'll settle
it you know uh
social media has been covered with uh
robin williams you know yeah the debtor
robin williams and it's very sad
when anybody dies in any way form you
know this is a little sad it's closer
home for comedians and people who like
movies and entertainment
you know and and
the general consensus are that comedians
are dark people and they
they have this and that you know listen
i could sit here
and like everybody else everybody became
a [ __ ] authority last week you know
i could sit here and tell you one thing
i've
gone through a lot of little things and
i have gotten gotten down on myself and
gotten depressed about my situation
but i've done something about it i don't
know anything about depression
i don't know how it starts it could be
hereditary you know i don't know if it's
in your genes i don't know i uh i
whatever it is i i my heart pours to you
it's just a different facet of our mind
playing tricks it's a brain fart you
know we have anxieties we have fears you
know
but i will tell you that sometimes when
i've had fears
i've been depressed because i haven't
overcome them
you know and that's why i
i tweeted that stupid thing that fear is
a cousin of depression you know so i i
didn't want anybody to be mad for a fact
that started to trigger in your mind
i really wanted david towel a call today
i really i spoke to him yesterday
briefly and i really wanted to talk to
explain the comic mind and the different
forms of comedians minds and i don't
know i don't know the mind i know my
mind and i know how my mind works and i
don't get depressed i do have dark
thoughts
and they race in my mind and they hit so
hard
that it shatters me for three minutes
and then i have to put it in a
wastebasket there's a wastebasket next
to me on my left and i put the shitty
thoughts in there and i've had to do
this
and yes when i went to the
psychotherapist that time for my anxiety
we discussed
the dark thoughts that i have and i
don't want to take medication because i
don't want to feed it
uh when you have a dark thought you
overcome it yourself or at least in my
mind that's what i do i know i'll get
emails from people saying you should go
on this pill you should go on that bill
and that's what i don't want to do
you know that's why i want to work this
[ __ ] out myself and that's what i've
always done you know i have
you know this week i was telling lee
that
uh
i had a problem with my wife this week
and whatever because of my uh temper
with the baby you know
uh i fly for a living
and i flown in the back of the plane i
flown the front of the plane and from
the ages of one to five it's very hard
to travel with a child
you know
and i get to see the other side of it i
get to see you know traveling used to be
flying used to be a great experience lee
i don't know if you have a flu as a
child i had a child but still it was
already kind of i remember we used to
have the they would give you silverware
like actual metal for the for the meals
but that ended quickly like by the time
i was a little kid it was already
terrible but it was always supposed to
be a good experience but you're supposed
to be excited and even as an adult
you're supposed to be excited when you
fly when i fly now it's just a pop my
own business
but i don't like it either and every day
you read how there's terrorism and this
and that you know or you can't out do
life
but you can hire your percentages by
doing certain things or not doing
certain things you know and i was just
very scared that mercy was gonna fly you
know that's it and because of that fear
of mercy it bled over into all my other
aspects of life and it made me angry all
week and it really did affect me and we
worked it out and whatnot but
it's amazing that i was getting dark
thoughts
that's why they want mercy to fly you
know i actually saw the terrorists on
the plane smacking my child you know
i see those things in my mind
and that's what happens with me
you know i don't get thoughts dark
thoughts you know my my heart goes out
to him
how uh he ended up dying and i don't
know what he was going through
you know i hope that god has as uh
mercy
in his hand you know when he touches him
i don't know
but i will know that uh it was just very
sad oh it's true i have people very
close to me in my life who who went
through it and
it's uh
it's great that you can go through it
and not have to take the pills but i
know people i know multiple people who
have taken it and changed their lives
and it's uh
i had like three or four people within
like two years of me graduating that
have committed suicides and it's just uh
i i
i don't even want to say depressed
because when when people kill themselves
from depression like why i was just
having a bad week or
or something but i've had bad thoughts
when i've been down but
i've never i've never seriously
considered that at all
and it's just i can't imagine what you
must be going through
fear twists
people up it twists me up
it twisted me up to the point where i
was asking my wife about missing money
like i thought i was missing money from
my checking account like did you take it
that's how deep the fear took me this
weekend that's what it did to my
thoughts it made me delusional oh wow so
i get it i get it guys and i've always
had those little things when something's
scares the [ __ ] on me it's like i get
crazy i lose my
equilibrium so
the mind works
in a [ __ ] weird way man the mind
works in a weird way and
we did we touched on it the other night
but there was too many people in the
room so i really couldn't blow my heart
into it i'm not the type of person
that's going to write something on
facebook man
i just i don't like that [ __ ] you know i
have to write everything on facebook to
let people see it my facebook is to get
you people up in the morning to crack a
stupid joke and to move on with my life
i really don't want to start writing
sentences in my life
experiences of robin williams i just
don't like that [ __ ] i know what
happened and i don't have to tell nobody
but i in the podcast you have to address
it because
people are listening and they're going
what the [ __ ] you know i know he was a
comedian you don't feel anything yeah i
feel something i feel scared i feel
scared for myself you know for a couple
days it did affect me you know was i
great friends with robert mums no we've
seen him that one time yeah down in town
i saw him one night at the improv and i
said hello
and i saw him a couple times at the
store and i said hello i didn't really
know oh my i didn't really have a
conversation with him you know did he
intimidate me nah i just didn't really
talk to him i just didn't
but after what i saw on twitter and read
on twitter you know everybody's a
[ __ ] authority you know i'm not an
authority of anything i'm an authority
of what i live through right and i don't
live through depression i just live with
shitty [ __ ] thoughts yeah
and uh they scared me and they scared me
at night and there's times i gotta take
my breathing mask off at night and catch
my wits and wipe my tears off my eyes or
something but
that's what it does to me i ain't gonna
kill myself
so i love you guys and thank you for the
concerns and the emails i answered 90
something emails yesterday wow a lot of
them were talking about that people with
depression people with
you know uh mental anguish anxiety you
know it just it's overwhelming you know
i had an anxiety-driven
uh i had an anxiety driven
addiction where if the coat wasn't in my
body at a certain time the anxiety was
so overwhelmingly that i'm happy i
wouldn't talk to people in that time
you wouldn't understand me if i came to
you and grabbed you by the shoulders i
would say lee i just need 60
and the more you would say joey i don't
have lee i need 60 [ __ ] dollars okay
and you would see it in my face and
finally go okay man calm down you know
that's the same thing
that's the same thing it made me crazy
so i'm crazy i get it
but uh i just didn't like how people
made a scene all right we're all these
we go back to our [ __ ] rooms and cry
and we're monsters inside and that's not
the fact i go to dinner all the time
with comics afterward and they're
[ __ ] fine you know and uh
that's part of it right part of it you
know
to do this to do this career people
think about it you got to be [ __ ]
crazy
you got to be [ __ ] crazy but then
again to be a doctor you have to be
crazy to do what paula does you have to
be [ __ ] crazy you know when somebody
tells you they're going to law school
you look at them and go
do you know you're getting yourself into
when somebody tells you they're pre-med
you know what makes a [ __ ]
[ __ ] look at his family and go
hey ma
i know i got a degree in [ __ ]
political science but guess what i'm
gonna choose the life of a [ __ ]
comedian i'm gonna go broke for four
[ __ ] years and live like a peasant
and crack jokes and make people laugh
and and somewhere in my mind i'm gonna
believe that i'm gonna become [ __ ]
famous doing this [ __ ] i'm gonna come
become successful doing this [ __ ]
because there's one thing doing comedy
and there's another thing making uh you
know a living off a [ __ ] comedy these
are the things you talk yourself into so
now you look at the list of comedians
how many comedians what's the population
of the united states i don't know what
what do we got 10 000 comedians if we're
[ __ ] lucky
those are all crazy people how many
people do you think are around that do
what you do and travel to like the good
comedy clubs every week
a lot you know like 300 comedians travel
you know you got to figure this 500
comedy clubs another [ __ ] 3 400
venues of weekends there's a lot of
comics working there's a lot of ships
there's a lot of things going on for
comedians you know and uh just to get
into that just to get into that career
there's got to be something wrong with
you and for some people they need
attention and for some people it's an
outlet and for some people it's therapy
you know it's all it's your own personal
[ __ ] jesus it's your own personal
jesus for what you want it to be for me
for me it was my last escape
i did not know i would be here 20 years
later i never anticipated being in
california
for me i just i would have been happy
just staying locally we discussed this
the other day on the podcast wednesday
night with the musicians we discussed
how i thought i could just get a job
and do comedy as an outlet i never
thought i would do anything greater than
that or anything more than that but
because of comedy this is where i ended
up and i took it i accepted it i opened
up my heart and i [ __ ] accepted it so
that's the
that's the moral of the [ __ ] story
that you got to be crazy to do this
mm-hmm okay i don't know why people made
you know i understand we lost a great
talent last week but it's amazing how
all these [ __ ] people came out of the
woodwork with their own things about the
human mind
and i have no [ __ ] idea all of a
sudden we didn't know he was crazy look
at early robin williams [ __ ] early
early a catch a rising star those
performances he was [ __ ] nuts yeah
you know i bumped into him in 1985
this is a true story i bumped into him
in snowmass village at the mall there at
the we used to be a store used to be
commander video
and he would come in there and one day
he came in and i saw him and as soon as
he walked in guys i smelled him
he smelled like b.o that's when he was
doing blow
and he he wouldn't sign moscow on the
hudson for me i asked him because he
signed moscow and hudson he said no and
he ran out of there and it shocked me
you know but i could tell then there was
some
something you know something yeah
or something so let's kill this subject
right now i mean my heart just goes out
to him i just think it's like kind of
how we were talking about how people are
negative about the ice bucket challenge
that some people like oh well why do we
care that this comedian killed himself
and and there's people who do it every
day i think hopefully what will happen
is
is that just because everyone loves
robin williams is that hopefully someone
who
was getting close to that will get help
but yeah you're right i mean it's not
just it's not everything
one [ __ ] person yeah if it helps one
[ __ ] person
then
it was great that it was brought to
light a lot of people sit at home and
don't know what's happening to them
a lot of people whether it's sleep apnea
whether it's depression creeping up on
them they don't know what's happening to
them they just think they're having a
bad day and they're gonna come out of
this fog in a week they really don't
people don't know what's what they're
walking into every [ __ ] morning guy
so my heart goes out to you if you have
depression or you feel something you
know [ __ ] the money go get help you know
whatever call somebody talk to people
you know uh
that's the number one thing i had a
friend that had the beginnings of it and
i would talk to him and even me as crazy
as i was i'd never
i never tiptoed around that but i never
was really full tilt joey diaz because
phil fulto joey d has a work with you
three or four times and then after that
he'll grab you by the shirt and tell you
not what's wrong with you but all the
good things that are going on in your
life and this is why you have to
overcome this
because you do have all these good
things that depression just tells you
all the bad things in your life i'm
gonna come in and grab you by the
[ __ ] neck and tell you you're a bad
[ __ ] and that you have one bad
thing so take care of it because if you
don't take care of it it'll bleed into
all your other good things like the coke
addiction i had it's no different all
these things you don't think they affect
you but they bleed into every single
avenue of your life when you're a
carpenter if you look up and hit your
[ __ ] nail with the thing it affects
your career it affects you in every
single way it also affects you when you
go out you know what do we know what
these cops are going through
did you ever think of that so before i
judge anybody on this situation whether
it's ferguson i always think about what
were they going through the minute
before this happened
that cop from ferguson did he just come
from a domestic violence dispute where
the guy had a knife
that he just see somebody you understand
bro there's so many variables
you know when they did that that
colonoscopy and they put me out they
said to me they made somebody come and
drive could i drive home [ __ ] yeah i
could drive home but they made somebody
come and drive because they said you
might make bad judgments the day i
kidnapped bella who called here the
other day while we were doing a podcast
i had done one of those things i could
have fought it in court and said that
hey i was put out i couldn't make a
choice
listen let's face it i [ __ ] kidnapped
that kid and took those drugs i knew
exactly what i was doing yeah the point
being is that i don't even know what the
[ __ ] point being is the point being
is that it's monday august 18th all
right and it starts all over again today
so what you drank over the weekend it
starts today so what you smoked the
cigarette over the weekend eight today
so what you ate 15 taco bells
it all starts all over today that's the
beautiful thing about [ __ ] monday
mornings let me give a [ __ ] uh shout
out to my sponsors here as usual one of
my favorites in fact i was thinking
about how i'm gonna take two shroom
texts today to go to jiu jitsu on it.com
anna just sent me some strong bone right
after my surgery i will be on on its
strong bone all over again i bought i
got two things from them so i could
strengthen my ligaments and all that
this is what honor does what other
[ __ ] corporate what other medical
what other optimization company gives
you something to strengthen your joints
go on it.com it's not a supplement it's
optimization it makes you great and if
you don't believe me just start with
alpha brain just go to [ __ ] honey
calm check out alpha brain buy the
smallest amount you can if it's not what
we say it is send it back no questions
asked we don't even want the product
back money back guarantee at the [ __ ]
alpha brain you'll just follow the steps
you'll say hmm let me try [ __ ] this
hmm my friend said that the [ __ ] uh
the egg enzymes are great for your
stomach hmm let me try one of their
kettlebells and i guarantee you just do
me a favor it starts with going to
honor.com look around go to the box if
you see something you like you press in
church in the box get 10 off your first
order also sign up for stay on it that's
when they mail it to you every month
automatically like the rest of the
products here that i try to sell to you
also one of my favorite people in the
[ __ ] world
huluplus.com all right how do you like
to watch huluplus.com they got niche
programming they got criterion
collection they got animation they got
kids they got original you can watch
huluplus.com anywhere anytime and it's
only
799 a month they got current episodes
that you can watch the shows on your
schedule you can watch shows on
everything any streaming device that you
have smart tv roku apple tv computer and
today only today only two weeks for free
8.99 a month all right 7.99 set whatever
that
that's how i roll 7.99 a month two weeks
free who gives you that who gives you
that type of excitement when you go to
your [ __ ] uh haircut does he cut your
hair to do for two weeks and then
charges you [ __ ] no but that's what
we're doing today if you get hulu plus
off the [ __ ] tv it's 7.99 a month
here at the church we give you two weeks
for free two weeks for free i don't give
a [ __ ] if you watch
to suck your dick you're gonna you're
gonna go [ __ ] this isn't that bad what
are they gonna do they press joey or
just go to joeyds.net and click on the
bell that's it give me your credit card
two weeks for free 7.99 a month another
one of my [ __ ] all-time favorites
dollar shave club what the [ __ ] do you
need a razor for with a flashlight and a
hood and a thinking cap and a finger up
your ass all you need are two blades to
cut you that are sharp precisely they
[ __ ] shave you one pulls the hair the
other one cuts it who the [ __ ] do you
think you're dealing with joy bananas
why are you gonna go stand on line with
the rest of these mutts at some pharmacy
looking around and pay 20 ounce for a
razor no more no more right let me get a
water i've got cotton mouth from that
candy thank you lee that's why i love it
i only took two waters today i'm over
here dehydrated that's why you go to
[ __ ] dollar shave club right now
first of all what do they do with hulu
plus
huluplus.com joey and dollar shave club
is
dollarshaveclub.com you get raises for a
dollar six dollars or nine dollars a
month right sent right to your [ __ ]
door not only that they got pre-shaved
they got the [ __ ] cocoa butter they
got the [ __ ] one white charlies
they're not [ __ ] around not a dollar
shave club so do yourself a favor
go to dollar shave club
get the razors delivered right to your
[ __ ] door boom you open them up you
get an email and they tell you when
they're gonna [ __ ] deliver them one
dollar you get four [ __ ] blades sent
to your month for six dollars you get
four double blades and for nine dollars
you get the double blades with the
[ __ ] aloe strip your face is nice and
smooth not only that you can shave your
[ __ ] you can shave your [ __ ] you can
shave your [ __ ] cat's [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] it's a tremendous razor go
to dollarshaveclub.com and press church
church church in the [ __ ] box and get
your dollar shave club today also i'd
like to welcome my main [ __ ]
hit e6.com
the proof is in the [ __ ] sig you
understand me 12 000 [ __ ] puffs
twelve hundred pups the [ __ ] uh cigar
or cigarette you get the cigarettes to
zero sixteen or twenty four or eight
milligrams of [ __ ] not thc nicotine
again nicotine no thc here don't be
[ __ ] calling me up and going joey i
got a [ __ ] eight milligram and
nothing came out i ain't stoned you're
not supposed to get stoned you're
[ __ ] momo hittiesticks.com what are
they pressing the box joey's church and
you get 20 off joey's church hit e6.com
they got cigars they got four [ __ ]
different type of cigarettes you don't
want nicotine they got that one too you
could sit there and blow smoke at
everybody's face on thanksgiving go to
heathen56.com and again i want to give a
shout out to sean jones for hooking us
up
they not only are [ __ ] great but
they're better tasting this cigar is a
[ __ ] next time you go to
atlantic city or bethlehem or whatever
casino you go to you walk in there with
a hidden sig and a [ __ ] bow tie on
who's better than you who's [ __ ]
better than you lee cut sucker nobody
nobody that's right that's right so
anyway what's up
nothing i'm stoned what's going on
something happened this week that really
this uh yesterday i was sitting there
i was feeding the cats and i was just
thinking i was watching the ufc mm-hmm
you know when they added uh josh kotzek
to the show and he was pretty funny he
took his tooth out and
i watch all that stuff you know i'm an
idiot and it's it's funny that i in a
way i i was like uh where's chael you
know because cheryl used to do that with
those guys and he's gone
and something over the week i went i
watched uh metamoros last week when he
got submitted and i and i read [ __ ]
about channel you know what i realized
something about you i was like i don't
like this [ __ ] guy anymore like i
just have no use for him at all anymore
there was a time when i liked him i
and then i started feeling bad for chad
and then i started realizing that the
reason why i didn't like you how old is
child son let right now the reason why i
was mad at channel sonnet
is because
of a [ __ ] you know listen man i'm not
the best looking guy in the world my
voice irritates me he's 37. there's a
lot of things that irritate me about me
the addiction when i used to get high
look at myself in the mirror and i poked
my face that's why i have these scars
it's
uh
there's the the thing i hated about the
quality i hated the most about myself
that i didn't even know i was doing
and i see it all the time and in a
couple weeks i came in here one morning
i was having a conversation with lee
and lee said something to me and it was
and and i didn't get mad at lee for what
he wasn't doing i got mad at lee
for saying it how he did and i went off
only and lee was mad at me for a few
days
and then we talked and it's so weird
when people don't claim responsibility
it
it destroys me
because you're not living to your
fullest
if you remove that thing from your life
oh my god your life gets so much better
if people had to ask me one thing
that helped me the most
was that i went up in front of that
judge and he told me i didn't claim
responsibility and while i sat in that
cell
yeah i had a good time and don't do it
and i laugh but i thought about that
line the whole time and not claim
responsibility
and it was so me i remember going in
front i remember bumping into the
district attorney ever at the
supermarket and burped in boulder and i
was talking to me and he looked at me
and he goes joey
we have an investigator we checked
you've been chucking and jiving all your
[ __ ] life and making people laugh
through everything and they forget oh
it's just joey you got to pay your dues
you got to do this man
you gotta come [ __ ] clean
and i would sit there and go you're not
supposed to come clean you know you're
supposed to no no no
especially when people trying to help
you you know and that was the thing that
bothered me most about
chael that he
his talent
wasn't up to par with his mouth
you know when he fought anderson when he
fought jon jones it was always his mouth
that got him the [ __ ] fight but then
when he get there he got the same result
over and over which is the same thing
the d.a told me when he said i was
chucking and jiving
that's what i was doing i was chucking
and jiving through my life
and then when i didn't instead of just
going you know what i mean after the
second time they caught him he's still
talking about to his kids he wanted to
get his wife pregnant and that's why he
did them and i sat there heartbroken
because you'll never grow as a human
being
and i know chao i know that he came
clean last week
but you know what in his heart he never
came clean and that was the biggest
thing that i overcame in my life forget
the [ __ ] forget the [ __ ] coke and
the [ __ ] being a piece of [ __ ]
criminal and the shoplifting and the
[ __ ] lying and everything i was doing
when i was at a young age
everything changed because i looked at
my perspective different of claiming
responsibility and you guys you sit
there going [ __ ] we're turning this [ __ ]
off joey's going on that rant about
claim responsibility because everybody
wants to move forward
but for me that was the biggest [ __ ]
hurdle and once i overcame it the world
opened up forget about cleaning up on
the drugs
forget it because even if i would have
cleaned up on the drugs lee i would
still not come clean with myself about
the things i'm doing
you know well it's easy it's like even
i'm sure you have points right now like
maybe what happened over the weekend
where
you were like oh i should have just told
my wife earlier or i don't know
in what way but sometimes even when i
try to it's easy sometimes to blame
other people and it feels good because
then you're not blaming yourself but
then when like when you look back you're
like oh i should have done that and oh
my god it's such a
it's such a you know what it's such a
[ __ ] i don't like people saying
something to me
i would hate i hate when somebody says
lily do me a favor pick up that piece of
paper you know you had to pick it up for
five [ __ ] days you know you gotta go
pick up that suit at the dry cleaners we
all know we gotta do [ __ ] and it's like
we it destroy and then when you tell me
the reason why you didn't do it i do the
same you know i do the same in my mind
but then i go you know what [ __ ]
everything now i got to get my car in
traffic and pay my dues for not going
you know that's how i be you know and
it's just so many different [ __ ]
things
you know the gym for me like right now
i'm talking to you but 10 minutes ago
when danny i was thinking about how i'm
going to work out today i have so many
different things do i have time to zip
into wilshire do the workout and zip
back i really don't today so that means
i got to run home do paperwork write a
little bit and then go to the park and
work out that's important to me but it's
amazing how when i would go on the road
i would never work out and give myself
excuses ah it's a [ __ ] up gym you can
still put sneakers on and walk yeah
you can still put sneakers on the wall
well i'm too i don't have money for a
gym you can still put sneakers on and
walk
like there's always an answer there's
always a [ __ ] answer you know
and uh that that's it i i i hope that
chael
overcomes this i overcame it at 26 and i
think i [ __ ] around with it for about
another year and then i got it and i
moved on and i gotta tell you it really
helped me
and some people might say oh well joey
sometimes in your actions you're kind of
uh
negative because you have to know
yourself
you have to know yourself and what what
limitations you have and whatnot what i
want to try something i'm not gonna
[ __ ] like
why i try everything i practice
everything i preach here you know i
practice [ __ ] getting up early i
practice [ __ ] doing something every
day all we need in this life is to be
one percent better every [ __ ] day
every day when i wake up i'm like you
know what i'm gonna do today i'm gonna
be a little better than what i was
yesterday i'm gonna say [ __ ] one last
time i'm gonna say [ __ ] one less time
i'm gonna say [ __ ] one last time i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna you know it's
just so many [ __ ] things and we'll
leave with that
we'll be back wednesday [ __ ] night
you savages
eight o'clock we got a great guest
coming in
don't worry about nothing you know we
always take care what's with the
questions what's with the questions
[ __ ] so chad i love you robin
williams my heart goes out to you and i
hope you [ __ ] had a great uh
podcast i know i had a great time it was
fun you know you have no shows coming up
i gotta do gots i got joeydiaz.net go on
there look at the dates i got coming up
go get yourself a g patch i'm finishing
up with these mugs and these geek
patches and this shirt and i'm moving on
i'm moving on i'm getting a hoodie
sweatshirt for the winter we're gonna
get you some new [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
so uh go there now oh if if anyone works
with leather i'm trying to do something
with leather so if you uh tweet me that
i appreciate it and that's it [ __ ]
i love you guys have a great weekend i
want to give a shout out to on it
huluplus.com
dollarshaveclub and headysigs.com right
as far as you [ __ ] are concerned
have a great day have a great week and
stay black now that the show's over
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial of hulu plus hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of fit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet support this podcast and get an
extended free trial of hulu plus when
you go to huluplus.com
or go to joeydiaz.net and click on the
hulu plus banner don't forget to sign up
for dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
ratios sent to your door each and every
month for a fraction of what you pay at
retail
now go to dollarshaveclub.com
church that's dollarshaveclub.com four
slash church or just go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the dollar shave club
banner also remember to go to onit.com
and you use codeword church to get 10
off your order of optimization tools
like alpha brand new mood show tech
anything like that and go to hit
esigs.com that's hit e the letter e
segs.com used